bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition du 7 8 sport je suis ravi de
vous retrouver tout de suite on passe au
sommaire en cyclisme le vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines a
vibré au rythme du cyclisme la semaine
dernière l'enceinte accueilli la coupe
de france à l'américaine et les
championnats ile de france sur piste
coup de projecteur sur ces deux
compétitions dans ce magazine en bas les
joueurs du psg étaient à saint quentin
en yvelines ce week-end ils ont
rencontré les moins de 15 ans du club de
montigny-le-bretonneux reportage à
suivre
boxe nous recevrons sur ce plateau à
saint affrique le directeur sportif du
boxing club de la verrière
il sera accompagné de jardin duick
champion de france dans la catégorie des
moins de 67 kg dotée au domingues et de
sabine hui qu ensemble nous parlerons
des excellents résultats du boxing club
cette saison
et puis en fin d'émission comme tous les
lundis vous retrouvez tous les résultats
sportifs du week-end dans le département
c'était l'un des évènements sportifs à
ne pas manquer la semaine dernière dans
les yvelines la coupe de france à
l'américaine était programmée ce
mercredi au vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines
une centaine de coureurs à participer à
la compétition le montage est signée
exhalant une compétition spectaculaire
la coupe de france à l'américaine était
programmée ce mercredi sur la piste du
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
ces disciplines se dispute avec des
sprints intermédiaires et avec des
équipes composées de deux coureurs cette
année des centaines de cyclistes venus
de toute la france ont participé à ce
rendez vous à tous les comités la décade
de sa vague de cas des élites y a
la d'échappement du monde en élite qui
sont ici des professionnels se routes
qui sont ici c'est vraiment très
important
c'est vraiment une belle épreuve dure
physiquement c'est toujours être devant
pour les sprints donc belle épreuve
une belle épreuve mais il épreuve
dangereuse où les contacts sont
fréquents une dizaine de chutes sans
gravité ont été recensés pendant cette
coupe de france à l'américaine c'est
américaines sont toujours très
spectaculaire surtout on va dire dans
les jeunes catégories lorsqu'on débute
lorsqu'on à 15 16 ans on n'a pas les
automatismes que peuvent avoir des
professionnels donc des chutes il y en a
évidemment ce tour odéon avec catégories
cadets juniors tracts le monde fait
attention et puis il ya déjà des
couloirs ils n'ont pas trop l'habitude
de cette discipline
voilà du coup ils passent ils face au
mauvais endroit au mauvais moment et
voilà c'est le risque c'est la course
phare attention mais ça frotte elle
plutôt énervé c'est une des courses
comme ça il ya de l'enjeu est donc ça
frotte ça brûle brûlures et charb
s'était brûlé seront sans aucun doute au
départ de la coupe de france à
l'américaine l'année prochaine la
compétition devrait être à nouveau
organisée dans l'enceinte du vélodrome
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
dans cette course à l'américaine c'est
le duo bryan coquard thomas boudât
d'europcar qui a fait le show en
remportant la course élite devant jordan
levasseur et benjamin thomas de l'armée
de terre nous l'avons rencontrée juste
après la course
new ceric bryan coquard qui vient de
remporter la coupe de france de
l'américaine trois mois après son titre
de champion du monde sur la même
discipline alors bryan coquard est-ce
que c'était une victoire facile
y'a pas il n'y a pas de victoire facile
c'est sûr qu'on en a fait le show n'a
fait spectacle on a pris plaisir je
n'étais pas dans des positions
extraordinaire avec thomas moi je sors
des quatre jours de dunkerque en étant
un stage avec l'équipe de france l'a
donc c'était beau à voir
c'était une course d'entraînement va
dire mais bon là bon c'est on a pris
plaisir on s'est bien amusé vous avez dû
puiser nombreuses réserves vraiment sur
cette compétition où vous en avez gardé
un petit peu sous le pied
on n'en a pas trop garder donc voilà on
en a vu beaucoup je crois on doit gagner
avec deux ou trois tours d'avancé mais
on a on ne va pas garder en avril
n'était pas faux fond mais on s'est fait
plaisir et se prenaient moins c'est de
faire la bagarre on est des compétiteurs
on a appris un sacre un petit matelas on
va dire et là l'équipe de leur médecin
vous a vraiment donné du fil à retordre
où les à les maîtriser
non moi je pense qu'on a pu les cerises
et voilà au bout de trente quarante
tours on avait déjà un tour d'avancé sur
caen après c'est une faute et un tour
d'avancé
beaucoup plus facile à gérer il ya plus
de yapi trop les classements affaires et
donc c'est pour ça qu'après ça nous a
permis de reprendre deux tours par la
suite et qu'est ce qui fait la
différence dans ce type d'épreuve
bon c'est beaucoup de technique on est
on se connaît très très bien avec tu
auras donc déjà techniquement je pense
qu'on est pas parfait mais on est parmi
les meilleurs du monde donc déjà c'est
je suis rendait ensuite passé une bonne
condition mais une bonne position va
vite tous les deux on peut prendre des
tours ont regagné les classements donc
on s'est un peu tout faire c'est
vraiment ça notre force
en tout cas c'est une compétition que
vous affectionnez oui on essaye de venir
de venir tous les os pour l'instant ça a
été possible ces deux dernières années
après des fois être calendrier route
c'est un peu plus compliqué mais on
essaye de venir voilà le plus possible
on était l'année passée on essaiera de
revenir l'année prochaine
merci beaucoup bagarre bryan coquard
toujours aussi souriant il y avait
également les championnats ile-de-france
au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ce week-end
une compétition qui a réuni dizaine de
délégations franciliennes dont vélizy
villacoublay
mélanie poké pour les images les
cyclistes franciliens étaient réunis sur
la piste du vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines pour les
championnats ile de france ce week-end
des délégations de vélizy de créteil de
parisi ou encore d'argenteuil se sont
affrontés pour monter sur la plus haute
marche du podium
la compétition était relevée on sait
très bien qu'il n'ya pas autant au
niveau que la france n'a pas authentifié
d'ailleurs c'est dommage
après je retrouve quand même obligé
montauban dans la finale donc voilà le
le niveau qu'on adore c'est quand même
pas mal pour un sommet régional parce
que je m'en serais pas déçue de région
lui seul à avoir un niveau comme celui
ci donc moment il les championnats
régionaux permettent avant tout de
découvrir les futures pépites du
cyclisme sur piste
on voit qu'il ya des jeunes qui montrent
le bout de leur nez qui déjà qu'ils vont
très vite après l'aspect tactique et
moindre parce que bas à cet âge-là je
n'ai pas écrit fléchir sais c'est dur
mais bon ils sont plus là appuyé fort
position équivalent que dorée prochain
mais oui mon actu sort que du lourd
parmi les jeunes les recruteurs ont dû
noter le nom de thomas my sur leurs
carnets le courant et giner de magny les
hameaux a terminé à une belle troisième
place dans l'épreuve de vitesse
le cycliste saint quentinois battu
alexis bojan de créteil lors de la
petite finale
je gagne la première manche grâce à
plutôt la tactique la deuxième manche
lui tactiquement elle a mieux joué que
moi qu'il a lancé deux ils lancent deux
de plus près ce qui fait que j'ai pas pu
le vraiment leur montée et la dernière
manche va j'ai été à fond pour aller
chercher la médaille
thomas et participera à l'épreuve des
championnats de france en juillet après
la médaille de bronze le jeune sprinter
de cette fois-ci accroché l'or à son cou
tomas maier sportif saint quentinois à
surveiller de tout près après une large
page cyclisme en passe ou handball
les championnats de handball touchent à
leur fin montigny-le-bretonneux termine
3ème de nationale 2 féminine le chesnay
jouera un match de barrage pour accéder
à la nationale 2 masculine et versailles
rue
relégué en nationale 3 masculine pour
nous parler de cette fin de championnat
nous recevons sur ce plateau
gabriel parloir joueurs de montigny
bordelais bonsoir alors montigny a fini
à une très belle troisième place après
sa victoire donc 34 à 24 contre
villemomble
est ce que est ce que tout simplement le
contrat est rempli le contrat initial
est rempli et sachant qu'on avait parlé
de finir dans les cinq premiers
troisième vingt ont fini on finit bien
et avec l'association satisfaction aussi
de faire mieux que les dernières années
en idle
il est parti un petit regret sur cette
saison le petit regret ou effectivement
c'est qu'on termine 3e donc au pied du
podium on ne jouera pas les matches de
barrage
on a eu un moment de creux cette saison
avec plusieurs défaites consécutives et
puis on le paye au final mais là c'est
le sport et qu'est ce qui a fait défaut
à cette équipe c'est peut-être l'aspect
psychologique le mental parce que vous
avez été première là au mois deux mois
de février et vous avez craqué suite
suite à cette première place
c'est mental vraiment qu'ils avaient
fait défaut je ne sais pas si c'est le
mental à prendre une équipe jeune il ya
plein de choses à construire il ya un
championnat qui en dents de scie donc se
mettre dedans relâché un petit peu se
remettre dedans c'était pas forcément
évident non plus les blessures les
implications personnelles tout ça au
final fait que ben on termine sur la
troisième marche du podium et la saison
prochaine vous viser plus haut du coup
je ne sais pas ça va dépendre de la
saison de l'équipe de la saison
prochaine
vous connaissez un petit peu les
contours de l'effectif de la saison
prochaine quand vous y serez ou pas pour
l'instant vous ne savez pas je ne sais
pas pour l'instant à bientôt et il ya
également donc les bonnes performances
du chéné qui sont qui sont à noter ils
ont gagné donc 26 24 contre la nuit ils
sont qualifiés pour les barrages
ils risquent d'accélérer nationale 2
masculine est-ce que c'est positif du
coup pour pour l'emballer guînois tout à
fait il était n 2 il n'ya pas si
longtemps je suis pas spécialement
le masculin mais c'est bien pour pour
les clubs du coin
après c'est vrai qu'il ya quand même pas
mal de club en national sur l'ouest
parisien
est-ce que ça serait pas intéressant
d'avoir l'équipe au niveau des yvelines
en n2 je sais pas s'il y en a d'autres
c'est jamais mauvais de toute façon et
versailles par contre de son côté a va
être malheureusement relégué après sa
défaite contre falaise calvados 24-23
sur le fil est ce que c'est une grosse
perte pour le en ballet viennois de
perdre versailles dans ses mains se
battre pour le club en lui-même je
suppose que oui après pour le handball
dans le coin je sais pas je sais que
même si c'est pas les éviers unis à
chaville issy les moulineaux ventes qui
sont pas très loin
le chesnay aussi en n2 donc en termes
d'effectifs ça peut être compliqué
j'imagine de trouver une bonne équipe
avec les bons joueurs faut des arguments
assez solide pour aller faire venir dans
un club je sais qu'il rencontrait des
problèmes financiers mais après je pense
qu'ils se sont bien battus ils ont une
première partie de saison difficile et
ils finissent avec de bons résultats ça
ne suffit pas malheureusement donc
qu'ils connaissaient stéphane paysans
l'entraîneur est ce qui les a abattus
enfin vous pensez qu'il a battu après
cette défaite je pense parce que c'est
un compétiteur il n'aime pas perdre chez
oui oui j'ai eu le coach quelques années
et la défaite il déteste ça donc
j'imagine que ça lui fait mal au coeur
de terminer sur une descente ils
risquent de partir du coup à la fin de
la saison
vers un autre club sur accès cieux voilà
mais est ce que est ce que justement les
joueurs vont devoir va devoir tout
reconstruire ce club les joueurs
l'entraîneur et les dirigeants doit tout
reconstruire
ça va dépendre des choix du bureau
j'imagine
qu'est ce qu'il souhaite faire quel
projet de club quels sont les choix des
joueurs
je connais pas assez le club 5le
également qui a beaucoup de supporters
ils ont joué à guichet fermé là il ya
quelques jours la ce week-end il ya
notamment les ultras royal blue leurs
supporters leur corps de supporters est
ce que pareil pour les supporters c'est
un gros choc déception sans doute mais
après ils ont fait leur travail des
supporters ils ont été là jusqu'au bout
pour soutenir leur équipe
et j'imagine qu'il est souvent le
soutiendrons à l'avenir aussi merci
gavrelle parloir d'être passé sur ce
plateau est donc souhaite bonne chance
pour vos projets futurs ou peut-être à
montigny lautner merci toujours handball
trois joueurs du paris saint germain se
sont rendus ce samedi au complexe pierre
de coubertin à montigny-le-bretonneux
ils ont rencontré à cette occasion les
jeunes dieux du hand de montigny au
programme coaching et c'est en ce
délicat c'est xavier jaglin pour le
montage cette journée restera sans doute
gravée dans leur mémoire samedi trois
joueurs du psg handball zacharia n'diaye
patrice annonay et jeffrey m tima sont
venus animer un entraînement des moins
de 15 ans de montigny le bretonneux
le club saint quentinois remporté un
concours organisé par le paris
saint-germain on a participé au
challenge voile comme pas qu'organise le
psg l'année dernière c'est à dire que
les clubs qui emmène des gens voir les
matchs légende balle marque des points
on s'est avéré
être le club qui a mené le plus de gens
voir les matchs du psg et donc on a
gagné les lots de ce fameux challenge le
come back dans un entraînement animé
comme vous allez pouvoir par les joueurs
du psg sur le site du club en gagnant
les joueurs du psg ont profité de cette
session pour donner des conseils aux
jeunes
objectif les faire progresser pour
qu'ils deviennent professionnels dans
quelques années j'ai observé un petit
peu tous les gardiens de but et j'essaie
de leur donner quelques petits conseils
assez simple juste dans l'observation et
loïc j'ai vu j'ai pu observer qu'il a
déjà les qualités assez dynamique dans
le but est à mais je crois qu'il ya
encore des petits travail de mes
sensations et de placements en fait donc
ce que je disais par exemple les tirs à
six mètres d'avancé pour ces bouchers
langues et pour le maximum de place à
quoi le ressort des conseils mais c'est
bien après je peux essayer de les fermer
à 6 mètres faut avancer
après bah faut pas trop baisser quand on
fait l'arrêt une journée pleine
d'enseignements que les jeunes joueurs
de montigny le bretonneux n'oublieront
pas s'embarrasser des grands joueurs
connus
ça fait plaisir de les voir pire on voit
que
ce qu'on pourrait devenir plus tard
peut-être si on a persévéré
ça m'a fait plaisir ils nous ont donné
des conseils de ça c'était savoir c'est
déjà ma passion mais là ça l'est encore
plus ça donne envie ben d'être comme
nous après je pense que et vont tout
faire pour les bas pour aller au plus
haut niveau et peut-être s'il ya match
vu quelques potentiels et je pense que
si qu il continue à travailler je pense
qu'il peut arriver on dans le même
bassin de formation ou aller dans un
grand club
montigny le bretonneux participera à
nouveau challenge
welcome pack la saison prochaine les
joueurs du psg pourrait donc foulé une
nouvelle fois le terrain du complexe
sportif pierre de coubertin
les plus jeunes ont également fait du
sport ce week-end dimanche celui en
cours en partenariat avec l'entente
athlétique de saint quentin en yvelines
organisé une compétition de dca poussins
un v4 longue pour les enfants puis de 50
enfants participent à ce rendez vous
programmé au stade maurice baquet les
images sont signés à mélanie poké une
compétition d'athlétisme un peu
particulière était programmé ce dimanche
au stade maurice baquet à guyancourt
une cinquantaine d'enfants du club de
l'entente athlétique saint quentin en
yvelines a participé un déca poussins
une journée sportive dédiée aux jeunes
âgés de 6 à 12 ans donc le nom c'est à
partir du décathlon on regroupe dix
épreuves du décathlon pour adultes con
con mais au niveau des enfants pour
qu'ils puissent essayer toutes les
épreuves sans s'en être dans la
difficulté qu'un humain pourrait avoir
sur des vraies épreuves de décathlon
parce que c'est quand même assez
épuisant
donc vous avez tous les lancers qu'on
adapte il ya toutes les courses et tous
les sauts les exercices ont été encadrés
par les membres du club ces bénévoles
ont donné de précieux conseils pour
réaliser au mieux les activités
le saut à la perche était l'une des
épreuves les plus techniques de ceux des
capucins si on est droitier on met la
main droite en haut et la main gauche on
la met
au niveau de l'aisselle messieurs les
gauchers on met la main on met la main
gauche au dessus et la main droite au
niveau de l'aisselle gauche ce qui m'a
vraiment plu c'est le saut en longueur
et pourquoi pas ce que j'allais bien ici
vient le salon gars tu feras ton est là
et puis havrais du coup je cours et tu
dois aller le plus loin possible
les enfants ont pu réaliser des
performances de haut niveau sous le
regard de leurs parents là c'est super
il fait beau en plus et puis bal et la
compétition c'est bien pour eux aussi en
dehors de l'entraînement ça ni les
pousse un peu plus donc c'est bien ça
doit parler se dépense et surtout ça
permet aux parents de voir ce qu'ils ont
fait tout au long de l'année
donc pour ça c'est sympa la prochaine
édition du déca poussin est prévue pour
mai 2016 les enfants maintenant un an
pour s'entraîner aux lancers à la course
et au saut c'est sûrement l'un des clubs
de boxe des yvelines qui façonnent le
plus de talent le boxing club de la dr
enregistre de très bons résultats dans
ces catégories de jeunes pour nous
parler de cette réussite nous recevrons
sur ce plateau à saint affrique le
directeur sportif de la verrière jordan
duick nouveau champion de france dans la
catégorie des moins de 73 kg théo
domingues boxer dans la catégorie des
moins de 51 kg et sa vie lui que boxer
chez les moins de 42 kg alors à sa
nourrice qu'est ce qui explique les bons
résultats de votre club
bon pour certains le travail pour
d'autres un petit peu de chance
et puis voilà quoi ça que c'est une
année de transition après l'an passé où
on était premiers clubs nationale c'est
comme quelque chose de plutôt rare on
aurait pu leur nouvelle à la chose
avec les cadets que je n'ai pas emmener
parce qu'ils s'investissent et pas
suffisamment à mon goût mais donc j'ai
privilégié d'abord l'éducatif avant
d'avant le côté sportif
voilà et c'est le côté peut-être un peu
un peu dur de votre méthode peut être
non qu'elle s'élance non parce que là on
parle vraiment même pas de difficulté
dans le travail c'est vraiment un
problème d'assiduité et d'engagement
voilà et donc les bons résultats sont
ponctuées par un titre de champion de
france donc de jordan ce titre de
champion de france ça t'as fait quoi le
gagner ça m'a fait plaisir parce que
quand j'ai commencé à beaucoup je me
disais que j'allais faire un nom avant
de faire les championnats et donc ça m'a
fait plaisir
il ya aussi des jeunes qui poussent un
c'est notamment le cas de théaux a fini
à une belle 3e place lui théo ça te fait
quoi dans ce club c'est vraiment le
travail tous les jours c'est ça ça qui
fait la réussite de ce club oui et puis
ça m'a beaucoup aidé puis j en suis très
content d'être arrivé à ce point là sa
récompense un peu mais à fort là où je
voulais y aller et à ce que ces jeunes
méritent leur place
théo il mérite mieux que la médaille de
bronze
c'est que c'est un enfant qui est plutôt
acharnée au travail c'est une évidence
il change de club aussi donc il était
dans un autre club il est venu chez nous
pour entre guillemets touche heroes
niveau de la boxe éducative
donc voilà mais ce soir je pense que la
voie il a atteint son objectif parce que
d'avoir auparavant il n'avait jamais
dépassé le niveau régional il avait même
jamais été champion régional si je me
trompe pas c'est bien ça donc voilà donc
appartement on a été champion régional
on a la mission était un petit peu était
un petit peu
est un petit peu réussie et pour
l'interrégional encore et pour une fois
qu'il est partout cher que la france
forcément on progresse la boxe ça joue
énormément dans la tête vous voulez
préparer mentalement aux compétitions
bon la boxe éducative ça on n'est pas
encore sûr de la boxe au monde amateur
ou la boxe professionnelle
voilà c'est quelque chose d'assez là
c'est quand même dire plutôt ludique on
n'est pas sûr du travail acharné comme
d'hab hawks amateurs ou de la boxe trop
peut-être certains y arriveront un jour
comme ça que c'est une c d'autres
méthodes avec le même entraîneur en
l'occurrence moi mais c'est avec la boxe
amateur c'est une transition entre la
boxeuse in a box à venir tu peux être
très difficile la prochaine boxeuse
aussi qui risque d'avoir du succès à
l'avenir c'est s'habille adweek toi dans
ce club parce que tu te sens bien ce que
tu penses que tu peux progresser et à
l'encadrement pour progresser oui je
pensais progresser tous clette et hassan
du couteau coach bien qu est-ce qui est
ce qui te dit à l'entraînement explique
moi un petit peu d'entraînement
classique le traitement classique il
sautait de toucher il pas reculer quand
on a comme comme j'avance ce que j'avais
j'ai touche pas assez
et est ce que ton coach dur avec toi
nous tous c'est plutôt une relation de
complicité
hassan vous pendant les combats vous
voulez laisser comment le vous protégez
vous laisser vraiment faire ce qu'ils
veulent et près vous corriger ou vous
êtes plutôt dans dans l'analyse sur le
sur le match pendant que vous êtes en
train de caen qui sont en train de boxer
mal bon entraîneur ses entraîneurs qui
s'adapte effectivement on
il faut savoir que c'est un sport duels
donc impression c'est un sport duels on
s'adapte aussi à la stratégie qui est
mise en place en face après quand tu
honores championnat ce qui était le cas
par exemple hier on a passé une journée
de boxe éducative à la ville d'orly donc
là c'est vrai on est moins on est on est
ce qu'on les laisse un peu plus s'amuser
un peu plus valent à s'exprimer
librement
et après seraient cantonnés sur du
championnat on est sur du compétitif
pure entre guillemets et là on voit là
on a plus de stratégie on s'adapte
justement à l'adversaire pour pouvoir
remporter l'assaut et vos techniques de
travail est-ce que évoluent au fur et à
mesure du temps où est-ce que vous
gardez la même stratégie à chaque fois
tout ça c'est des questions ps et des
questions sakho seront enfin on s'y
attarde pas énormément
est ce que mes évolué oui peut-être
qu'elle se durcissent un petit peu parce
que justement on se rend compte que ba
la transition entre la boxe éducative et
la boxe amateur elle et elle n'est pas
si évidente que ça
si on reste sur la préparation à la boxe
éducative sa demande pas énormément de
préparation physique et donc contre 103
en boxe amateur ils ont tout de suite la
difficulté ils se rendent pas compte
d'eux mais je comprends pas en boxe
éducative qui ne demandait pas çà et là
maintenant tu nous demandes ça c'est
difficile donc là peut-être que cette
année j'ai essayé d'un petit peu rendre
certains entraînements alors bien sûr
que quelques entraînements un peu plus
difficile pour peut-être emmené quelques
uns en boxe amateur s'ils en sont
capables et à ce que ce club peut viser
plus haut plus aux deux titres de
champion de france au plus haut c'est
pas un objectif
enfin déterminant c'est que c'est sûr
qu'on quand on fait du sport peu importe
le sport
d'autant plus quand on est entraîneur on
est là pour pour percer au haut niveau
mais enfin c'est pas quelque chose
d'essentiel c'est très important mais ce
n'est pas essentiel l'essentiel c'est
surtout de former bas des futurs adultes
mes gamins qui travaillent bien à
l'école des gamins qui se comporte
correctement avant toute chose merci à
tous les cas d'être placé sur ce plateau
bon courage pour la suite on vous
souhaite de gagner ses nombreux titres
de champion de france et et vous de
continuer dans cette voie pour gagner
vos titres également en passe maintenant
au reste de l'actualité sportive dans le
département on début de cette page
résultats par du football en promotion
d'honneur trappe rate le coche les
hommes de molsheim a aussi qui s'était
imposé 3-2 cette semaine sur leur
terrain contre le pec en match en retard
ont lourdement chuté sur leur terrain
contre parisienne score final 4-1
conséquences au classement cette défaite
stoppe trappe dans sa belle progression
au bord de la relégation pendant une
grande partie de la saison les
trappistes se sont ressaisis pour
remonter une belle cinquième place ces
défaites pour les condamnés dans la
lutte pour le podium toujours handball
mais cette fois ci chez les hommes le
chesnais n'a fait qu'une bouchée de
serris val d'orge dans leur salle les
yvelinois l'ont emporté 30 alice et dans
un match maîtrisé de bout en bout
enfin on referme le c7 huit sports par
un rendez-vous les templiers d'elancourt
se déplace ce samedi à 14 heures sur le
terrain des cougars de
saint-ouen-l'aumône pour le match pour
le dernier match de la saison dans ce
championnat élite
sixième au classement les tant pis n'ont
plus rien à jouer une victoire leur
permettrait de souffrir le leader et
préparer dès à présent la saison
prochaine si vous voulez soutenir les
élans courtois le match est programmé au
stade escutes arrêt à
saint-ouen-l'aumône
vous pouvez également suivre la
rencontre en direct sur le site internet
dailymotion en tapant templiers tv
c'est la fin de ce set 8 sport merci
d'avoir suivi je vous retrouve là mardi
prochain pour un nouveau numéro
très belle soirée sur tv fil 78